voglio farvi vedere una diapositiva una
slide si chiama così una foto voglio che
capiate la prima emozione che visse
uscita
siete pronti potete rispondere non è
vietato
ok ce l'avete l'avete colta allora
sentite qualche cosa che vi è arrivata
attraverso questa immagine che cosa vi è
arrivato che cosa vi ha trasmesso
l'immagine il colore della pelle il
colore degli occhi lo sguardo
cos'è che vi ha colpito di questa
bambina a parte ovviamente la tenerezza
la dolcezza la bellezza di questa
bambina
la cosa che notate è il sorriso lo
vedete è piccolissima eppure tramite il
sorriso vi sta trasmettendo qualche cosa
che avete percepito in questo momento e
si tratta solo di un immagine non ce
l'avete di fronte ed è incredibile la
forza che ha un sorriso voi lo sapete
che quando nasciamo noi siamo
fisiologicamente portati a sorridere la
bocca si piega così già appena nati poi
intorno alle cinque settimane
iniziamo un po a capire che quella
macchia bianca e la faccia del papà o
della mamma che si avvicina e quindi
abbozziamo un po di più ad un sorriso
reale quando riconosciamo questa macchia
perché ancora vediamo un po tutto
offuscato poi passa ancora il tempo
cresciamo e questa forma di
comunicazione lo diventa davvero perché
il sorriso quando abbiamo ormai quattro
mesi è formato e diventa un espressione
del viso
quindi da piccoli abbiamo la bocca così
con le labbra che si tirano gli occhi
che si stringono e quindi abbiamo questa
forma che diventa comunicazione in tutti
gli effetti socializzazione a sei mesi
a sei mesi il bambino non parla ma
comunica con il sorriso c'è una frase
anonima per cui non paga la siae sono
molto felice che questa cosa che dice
noi sorridiamo tutti nella stessa lingua
ed è vero cioè noi socializziamo tramite
il sorriso ed è fantastico come un
messaggio così diretto così potente così
forte
passa attraverso l'espressione del viso
e non solo il sorriso non è una cosa che
impariamo per imitazione
non è una cosa che ci viene insegnata ce
l'abbiamo dalla nascita ce l'abbiamo
tutti
non ci credete facciamo un esperimento
allora adesso
cercatevi cercate una persona che non
conoscete tra il pubblico voltatevi al
mio via vi guardate fissi negli occhi e
vi sorridete d'accordo proviamo 123
fatelo ok
allora avete visto magari avete
incontrato l'amico avete scherzato con
la fidanzata eccetera ma probabilmente
rete incrociato qualcuno che non
conoscete di cui non conoscete la
religione si è fidanzato sposato se gay
se che ne so non lo conoscete
eppure in quel momento in quell'istante
quando vi siete guardati negli occhi e
vi siete sorrisi avete creato un
rapporto è vero non è vero
vi siete sentiti un po vicini avete
comunicato bene la potenza del sorriso è
incredibile perché è un linguaggio
universale che arriva diretto subito
immediato fortissimo un'energia pazzesca
guardate guardate questo ragazzo lo
vedete questo è un ragazzo che in questo
momento sembra quasi triste a questo
sguardo un po un po lontano un po
distante
guardate la differenza adesso è arrivata
all energia l'energia del sorriso
eppure non c'è niente di incredibilmente
diverso non è un suono non è un sapore
non è un odore è un'immagine la forma
del viso
quindi il sorriso è veramente un
linguaggio fortissimo universale e che
abbiamo a disposizione gratuitamente che
ci permette di fare delle cose
fantastiche
io ho un amico che voi conoscete
sicuramente che è mister brown un
signore inglese che ha voluto fare
qualche cosa con il sorriso perché nel
2010 c'è stato un terribile terremoto
che ha devastato haiti e mister brown ha
voluto fare una canzone per aiutare i
bambini che erano rimasti soli dopo il
terremoto però non voleva fare qualche
cosa di che ne so come succede spesso
purtroppo nella comunicazione dove parli
di tragedia
allora è più facile avvicinare le
persone e farle portare dei soldi mi
sembra voleva portare un sorriso e ha
fatto un progetto un progetto con degli
amici con cui ha creato questo disco una
canzone ha girato un video ad haiti con
i bambini di haiti
e questa canzone ha venduto 60.000 copie
l'avete sicuramente vista ha fatto un
discreto successo e tramite i soldi
raccolti mister brown è riuscito a
creare a realizzare una casa di
accoglienza per i bambini ad haiti con
la forza del sorriso perché dietro un
progetto con tante persone
la cosa che è stato il motore di questa
operazione è stato davvero il sorriso
come il testo della canzone what is the
mouth green thinking best of mouth smile
e come dice mister brown week and me che
bella war with a smile jonio fenis
quindi il senso è questo nella
comunicazione noi siamo abituati
spesso e volentieri a usare il senso di
colpa con il fidanzato con la fidanzata
il dolore invece se noi cambiamo il
nostro atteggiamento totale nella
comunicazione tutti i giorni con il
sorriso ci cambia la vita è come quando
entrata in un negozio e trovate la
commessa è entrato in un bar e trovate
il barista che è un po ostico magari ha
avuto una brutta giornata non vi sorride
ritratta male voi dite gli faccio un
favore ad andare non ci torno più
e lì il barista o la commessa ha perso
un cliente
pensate quando invece entrate in un
posto e vi salutano ciao come stai
vi cambia la giornata e la differenza è
solo lì questa piccola cosa che noi
chiamiamo sorriso che è potentissima e
ha un'energia incredibile quindi week
and make the war with a smile on your
face come dice mister brown e io spero
che il sorriso possa aiutarvi a
realizzare tanti progetti come questa
baby house che vedete
vedete tutti i bambini questi sono i
bambini ospiti questa baby house sono 50
orfani che vivono sono bambini da 0 a 5
anni
quello con i capelli bianchi sono io
anche se sono alto uguale mi riconoscete
perché ho i capelli bianchi in mezzo e
questa è la bibbia house che siamo
riusciti a realizzare e come io ho
realizzato il mio sogno
semplicemente con la forza e l'energia
del sorriso
vi auguro di realizzare i vostri sogni
ed ora vi lascio con mister brown is
back in town che la canzone che abbiamo
cantato per i bambini di haiti ad haiti
e mediante la quale la fondazione
francesca rava nph italia onlus oggi ha
potuto aggiungere un pezzo a quella che
è la grande storia che sta costruendo in
un paese così bistrattata grazie
sì
si no
la 6 wow flight 666
lei 6 b
quali
dias
si sapeva
si no